I WANT TO READ WHAT YOU SAID IN
YOUR BOOK REGARDING VLADIMIR
PUTIN.
YOU JUST MET HIM DURING YOUR
FIRST YEAR THEY'RE IN 2009.
AND YOU WRITE THAT POWER IT WAS
AS FROM HIM.
IN ALL MY MEETINGS WITH, PUTIN
HE GAVE NO SIGN THAT HE
RECOGNIZED A SHARED FUTURE ON
THE EUROPEAN CONTINENT.
FOR HIM, THE SENSE OF GRIEVANCE
WENT DEEP.
MOTHER RUSSIA HAD BEEN INVADED.
SACRIFICED ITS MILLIONS.
AND SUFFERED OVER CENTURIES.
HE WAS NOT THERE TO OFFER
FRIENDSHIP.
>> THAT DOES NOT BODE WELL FOR
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
NO, BUT IT WAS IMPORTANT EVEN
THEN TO KIND OF UNDERSTAND
WHERE HE CAME FROM.
RUSSIA HAD GONE THROUGH
TURBULENCE FOR DECADES.
IT HAD IN HIM, SO IT THOUGHT, A
LEADER WHO BROUGHT STABILITY OF
A KIND.
HE WAS PROUD OF HIS.
COUNTRY HE WAS VERY DETERMINED.
HIS COUNTRY, WAS IN HIS TERMS,
A MAJOR.
POWER NOT A REASONABLE POWER.
I THINK IT IS AN ACCUMULATION
OF IDEAS.
AND I THINK HE SAW THAT THE
WEST, IN BROAD TERMS, DID NOT
TAKE RUSSIA AS SERIOUSLY AS IT
SHOULD.
>> YOU FEATURE, ALONG WITH MANY
OTHER PLAYERS, IN A VERY
EXHAUSTIVE SERIES ON PUTIN
VERSUS THE WEST.
WHICH IS ON BBC RIGHT NOW.
YOU AND OTHERS SAY VERY SIMILAR
THINGS.
THAT ESSENTIALLY PUTIN IS A
LIAR.
THAT THAT IS PART OF HIS
DIPLOMATIC TOOLKIT.
AND THEN WHEN YOU GUYS GO TO
NEGOTIATE WITH HIM, YOU KNOW
THAT HE IS LYING TO YOU.
KNOWING THAT, HOW DOES ONE EVEN
NEGOTIATE WITH YOU NOW?
>> GOES BACK TO THE IDEA THAT
YOU'VE GOT TO VERIFY EVERYTHING
WHEN HE SAYS ORDAZ.
AND YOU HAVE TO START FROM THE
PRINCIPLE THAT HE IS NOT
TELLING YOU THE TRUTH.
HE IS TELLING YOU EITHER WHAT
HE THINKS YOU WANT TO HEAR ARE
SIMPLY WHAT IT SUITS HIM TO
SAY.
THE EVIDENCE HAS TO BE WHAT IS
GOING ON ON THE GROUND.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAYS.
WHEN WE HE SAYS WE HAVEN'T GOT
ANYBODY IN UKRAINE, AND YOU CAN
SEE THAT IT IS PRETTY OBVIOUS
--
>> AND THIS IS WHEN HE'S NOT
LISTENING TO YOU AND?
OTHERS >> THAT HE SEES THINGS
IN THE WAY THAT HE CHOOSES TO.
SO IN MAY, IT WAS ABOUT, IF WE
DO ALLOW UKRAINE TO HAVE THIS
TRADE AGREEMENT WITH THE EU, IT
WILL STOP ALL THIS STUFF COMING
ACROSS OUR BORDER.
HE WOULD SAY.
THAT IS CONTAMINATED OR NOT
GOOD ENOUGH.
OR WE DON'T WANT IT.
THE ANSWER IS YOUR BORDER
CONTROLS.
THAT IS NOT THE POINT IN HIS
VIEW.
IN HIS VIEW, IT IS ABOUT
LETTING IN SOME FORCE HE DOES
NOT WANT TO HAVE IN HIS
COUNTRY.
>> AND YOU, YOU WRITE IN THE
BOOK THAT THE FIRST MAJOR SAW
ITS OVER POTENTIAL CRISIS OVER
NEW, CURRENT AND THIS WHOLE
THING WITH EVERYONE CAN SEE
WHAT IT, IS WAS OBVIOUS TO YOU
IN NOVEMBER 2013.
ABOUT UKRAINE'S INITIAL ASK TO
HAVE A STRONGER PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENT WITH THE EU.
>> IT WAS A SPECIAL AGREEMENTS
THAT WAS TRADE.
PLUS CALLED AN ASSOCIATION
AGREEMENT.
AND THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE,
THAN, YANUKOVYCH, ONCE YOU TO
COME.
INSIDE IT HAD BEEN NEGOTIATED
FOR SEVEN YEARS.
THE INITIAL, DAY WHICH MEANT
ALL THE WORK HAD BEEN DONE.
AND ALL THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
HIM TO COME UP ON HIS NAME TO.
IT HE CAME TO THE MEANING AND
THEN --
AND IT WAS OBVIOUS PRETTY
QUICKLY.
I WANT TO SEE HIM IN KYIV AND
HE MADE CLEAR THAT THE REASON
IT WAS RUSSIA.
BOTH IN TERMS OF WHAT RUSSIA
COULD DO TO THEIR ECONOMY, BUT
ALSO IN TERMS OF HIS FEAR THAT
>> OF PUTIN >> YES, AND THE
RUSSIA WOULD SEE THIS IS A MOVE
TOWARDS THE WEST.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS.
>> TO ME THAT SHOWS THAT PUTIN
HAS NEVER WANTED UKRAINE TO
HAVE ANYTHING OTHER THAN AN
EAST WOODWARD VIEW.
DID NOT WANT UKRAINE TO HAVE
ANY WESTWARD LINKS THAT WERE
TOO STRONG.
SO WHEN HE SAYS THINGS IN HALF
THE WORLD BELIEVES IT IS ABOUT
NATO EXPANSION INTO THIS AND
THAT, IT'S BEEN GOING ON WAY
BEFORE THAT.
>> THE ORIGINAL REASON THAT HE
MOVED INTO --
WAS TO DEAL WITH THE EUROPEAN
UNION.
IT WAS NOT.
NATO NATO HAS BEEN ADDED AND
BECAUSE, AS HE SAYS, ALL THE
COUNTRIES THAT JOINED THE EU
THAT HAVE BEEN IN THE FULLNESS
OF THE UNION ALSO JOINED NATO.
SO HE SEES THE TWO, OR HE
CLAIMS TO SEE THE TWO, AS
INDIVISIBLE.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT THIS
WAS ABOUT TRADE AND ECONOMIC
ISSUES.
AND IT WAS ABOUT UKRAINE'S
DECISION TO TRY TO DEVELOP THIS
ECONOMY, IN A PARTICULAR MODEL
OR STYLE.
WHICH WAS EUROPEAN.
AND, THAT HE COULD NOT
TOLERATE.
>> WHEN YOU MET HIM FACE TO
FACE, WHAT DID HE SAY TO YOU
ABOUT YOURSELF OR THE WEST?
FOR INSTANCE, YOU DID GO TO
KYIV RIGHT AFTER THIS ISSUE IN
LITHUANIA.
ABOUT A MONTH OR TWO LATER YOU
ARE IN KYIV.
IT WAS IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
--
AND THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE WERE
VERY DISAPPOINTED, THERE WERE
PROTESTS AGAINST YANUKOVYCH
BECAUSE THEY HELD SIGNS.
YOU AND UKRAINE OR THE LIKE.
YOU WERE THERE, BEING SO
INVOLVED.
>> WE SAW THEM IN JANUARY FOR
REGULAR SIX MONTH SUMMIT AND HE
SAID TO ME THAT I SHOULD NOT BE
IN THE SQUARE.
MY ANSWER, WAS I DO WHAT I FELT
WAS NECESSARY.
>> AS I POINTED OUT TO HIM INTO
YANUKOVYCH, THE PEOPLE STANDING
IN THE SQUARE WHO ARE ALL SORTS
OF PEOPLE.
FAMILIES, YOUNG PEOPLE AND
JOURNALISTS, ACTIVISTS AND LOTS
OF LOTS OF PEOPLE FELT THAT THE
PROMISE THAT YANUKOVYCH MADE IN
THE ELECTION TO TAKE THEM INTO
THIS AGREEMENT HAD BEEN BROKEN.
BUT I SAW THAT WHEN I'M GOING
TO THAT SQUARE, THE ROLE OF
HOLDING EU FLAGS.
AS PRIME MINISTER IT IS MY
RESPONSIBLE INNOCENCE TO KIND
OF KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON.
I DID NOT STAND ON PLATFORMS IN
THE SQUARE.
I DID NOT MAKE SPEECHES IN THE
SQUARE.
THEY DID GO IN TALK TO PEOPLE
TO FIND OUT WHO THEY WERE AND
WHY THEY WERE THERE.
>> AND PUTIN LIKE THAT AT ALL.
>> HE DIDN'T.
BUT OF COURSE THE RUSSIANS
PARTICULARLY DIDN'T LIKE WHEN
THEY STARTED TO SEE POLITICIANS
ARRIVING.
UNDER MEMBER SERGEI LAVROV
SAYING TO ME AT ONE POINT, IF I
DO THAT EUROPEAN UNION COUNTRY,
WHAT WOULD YOU SAY?
>> IN RETROSPECT, DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT PUTIN HAS BEEN
ENCOURAGED BY THE EU AND THE
WEST?
AND IT'S RATHER TIMID REACTION
TO HIS INVASION AND ANNEXATION
OF CRIMEA?
YOU TALK ABOUT THE OFFICIAL
POSITION ON RUSSIA'S INVASION.
I KNEW THAT INVASION WOULD NOT
STAND, IT WILL BE TOO STRONG
FOR SOME COUNTRIES.
BUT IT WOULD BE A GOOD PLACE TO
START AND KEEP ONE FOR THOSE
BEFORE THEY DID NOT UNDERSTAND
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
WE SPENT SIX HOURS DISCUSSING
THE CRISIS AND LOTS OF
AMENDMENTS TO THE TEXT FROM.
MINISTERS THE WORD INVASION
BECAME ACTIVE AGGRESSION IN THE
FINAL TEXT.
>> THE PROBLEM IN A WAY WAS WE
DID NOT QUITE KNOW WHAT WE ARE
LOOKING AT.
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
SOMETHING GOING ON, YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT IS.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE IT IS
GOING TO END.
I REMEMBER VERY CLEARLY,
SITTING IN THE OFFICE ON THE
SUNDAY NIGHT BEFORE THE MEETING,
IN WHICH WE HAD TO DECIDE THE
WORDS.
AND WE DID NOT KNOW WHETHER
RUSSIA WOULD STOP OR KEEP
GOING.
SO I THINK THAT HOLDING ALL OF
THE COUNTRIES TOGETHER AROUND A
POSITION, THEY EXCEPT THAT THIS
WAS AGGRESSION.
WAS A GOOD, AND IT'S.
WAY NOW LOOKING BACK IT TURNED
QUITE QUICKLY INTO A SEMI
FROZEN CONFLICT.
IN FACT, THE LAST PLACE I WAS
BEFORE WE ALL WENT INTO
LOCKDOWN WAS ACTUALLY IN KYIV
AGAIN LOOKING AT WHAT IS GOING
ON AND I WAS QUITE WORRIED THAN
THAT WE HAVE SORT OF NOT REALLY
GIVEN THEM THE SUPPORT THEY
FELT THEY NEEDED.
IT DID NOT FEEL THE PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING AT THEM.
BECAUSE WE MOVED ON, BACK TO MY
AND THEN WHAT.
THINGS HAPPEN AND YOU KIND OF
DEAL WITH THEM AS BEST AS YOU
CAN.
THEN THE NEXT CRISIS HAPPENS.
AND THE.
NEXT AND PEOPLE MOVE ON.
>> IT IS INTERESTING.
I GUESS IT IS OBVIOUS FOR A
DIPLOMAT, BUT EVEN FOR SOMEONE
IS ADVERSARIAL AS PUTIN TURNED
OUT TO BE DURING YOUR TIME
THERE AND SENSE, YOU ACTUALLY
NEEDED THEM AND WORKED WITH
THEM CONSTRUCTIVELY ON SEVERAL
ISSUES.
FOR INSTANCE ON IRAN.
RUSSIA WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN
GETTING THE NUCLEAR DEAL.
>> ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I WAS FLYING FROM --
WHERE I BE SPENDING A WEEK WITH
THE RUSSIAN TEAM, INCLUDING THE
DEPUTY FOREIGN MINISTER SERGEI
REACT OF, TO --
WHERE I WAS STANDING ON THE
PLATFORM CONDEMNING RUSSIANS
FOR WHAT IT'S DONE.
AND THEN FLYING BACK.
LITERALLY, WE COMPARTMENTALIZE
ON BOTH SIDES.
WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
IT WAS QUITE EXTRAORDINARY.
AND INDEED, WHEN I MET PUTIN IN
MAKES HE MADE THE POINT TO ME
THAT THIS WAS NOT ABOUT IRAN.
WHERE WE WERE ALL WORKING
TOGETHER, AND WHERE WE WERE
CONFIDENT WITH WHAT WAS GOING
ON IN AND WHAT I WAS DOING.
IT WAS BIZARRE.
>> I'M INTERESTED TO HEAR WHAT
DO YOU THINK SHOULD HAPPEN
TRYING TO START UP NEGOTIATIONS
WITH IRAN TODAY.
AS IT'S HAMMERING PROTESTERS
AND EXECUTING PEOPLE PUBLICLY.
ON THE HUMAN RIGHTS ARE FINALLY
UNDER THE MICROSCOPE.
AND THERE IS NO DEAL AND THERE
IS NO NEGOTIATIONS, AND THE
AMERICANS ARE BASICALLY SAYING.
AND EVEN THE EU, BY THE WAY,
THE PRESIDENT SAID TO ME THERE
IS NO NEGOTIATION ON THE
NUCLEAR DEAL RIGHT NOW.
>> IT IS SHOCKING WHAT IRAN HAS
GONE TO HIS PEOPLE.
TRULY, TRULY SHOCKING.
IN A SITUATION WHERE IT IS --
TO BE SHOT WHAT IS GOING ON
THERE.
BUT IT IS BACK TO THIS POINT
ABOUT DIPLOMACY, WHICH IS FOR
ME THE DRIP DRIP DRIP STUFF.
IT GOES ON AND ON AND ON.
I NEGOTIATED FOR FOUR AND A
HALF YEARS.
AND I NEITHER STARTED NOR ENDED
THE JOBS.
AND THAT IS HOW IT HAS TO BE.
SO YOU NEED TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION IN SOME, WAY AT
SOME LEVEL, SOME WHERE, MOVING.
IN ORDER THAT WHEN YOU GET TO
THE MOMENT WHEN IT MIGHT BE
POSSIBLE AGAIN, YOU ARE THERE,
AND YOU ARE READY, AND YOU
CAN'T MOVE.
AND IT MIGHT NOT.
COME AND IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU
LIKE IT.
YOU DO NOT NEGOTIATE PEOPLE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO GO AND HAVE A
COFFEE WITH.
YOU NEGOTIATE PEOPLE WITH ME OF
A PROBLEM.